[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce premier set 8
sport de l'année 2018 le magazine y
construire et comme vous le savez à
l'actualité sportive du département
c'est parti à pour le sommaire football
où le petit poucet de la coupe de france
a été éliminée par concarneau club de
national une en 32e de finale de la
compétition les illinois se sont
inclinés 3 à 0 nous les avons suivis
pendant 48 heures reportage à suivre
basket on joue également en coupe de
france ce week-end le chesnay versailles
a frôlé l'exploit contre les espoirs de
châlons reims les yvelinois ont perdu 83
à 80 dans les toutes dernières secondes
retour sur cette élimination en quelques
instants découverte nous vous proposons
aujourd'hui de prendre de la hauteur
avec louis boniface jeunes vers les
voies n'hésite pas à défier la gravité
en faisant de la slackline un sport
proche du funambulisme où les sensations
fortes sont garanties nous le recevrons
dans quelques instants
coup de projecteur à présent sur les
principaux résultats du week end dans le
département
[Musique]
on commence donc par du football et les
32e de finale de la coupe de france le
petit poucet de la compétition où il n'a
pas réussi à créer l'exploit ce week-end
contre concarneau une équipe qui évolue
en nationale une cinq divisions au
dessus des yvelinois les pensionnaires
de régionale 3 se sont inclinés 3 à 0 à
domicile devant plus de 2000 spectateurs
retour sur ce rendez vous historique à
remontage de jules grenat ville jeudi 4
janvier à 19 heures l'atmosphère de la
coupe de france commence à envahir où
eut lieu le club qui évolue en r3 est
officiellement désignée petit poucet de
l'épreuve à moins de 48 heures de son
32e de finale contre l'équipe de
national une concarneau et je vends reçu
de la part des sponsors des maillot
collector symbole sur le terrain du
statut de plus petites équipes encore
engagées dans la compétition
thème 2 points et s'est fait au nombre
de surprises réalisé pour l'arrivée
jusque là nous avons éliminé trois
équipes qui étaient deux divisions au
dessus
et il semble que nous ayons donc mérité
une fois les maillots distribuer les
joueurs se sont rendus directement stade
maurice baquet futur théâtre de son 32e
de finale pour effectuer un dernier
entraînement
l'occasion pour l'entraîneur de rassurer
ses joueurs avant ce match historique
l'équipe de concarneau évolué cinq
divisions dessus des yvelinois ont joué
une montagne voulait qu'on pourquoi vous
les construit son risque rien on part en
part en part de loin
on est très loin de de concarneau qui
voulez je vous dise de plus faut pas se
prêter la presse on est très loin de
concarneau c'est une grosse grosse et
qui voulez que je vous dise quoi de plus
on se prépare on se fait plaisir et on
verra bien toute façon on n'a rien à
perdre
samedi 6 janvier 14h30 jours de match
les deux mille supporters prennent place
en tribune dans les vestiaires
concentration maximale à quelques
minutes d'entrer sur la pelouse
[Musique]
une fois sur le terrain la différence de
niveau se fait ressentir concarneau
marque deux buts dans les 15 premières
minutes dans une ambiance électrique 2 0
ce sera le score à la mi temps c'est
très compliqué on a fait une entame de
match très compliquée j'ai senti tendu
pas comme d'habitude ça fait partie du
sport une entame de match compliquée tu
le dis courage pas les supporters
présents au stade pour le premier 32e de
finale du club depuis 1940 à moi de sa
joue 90 minutes donc temps que le coup
de sifflet final il est bas
il est pas sifflé on peut toujours y
croire après je pense qu'il faut être
réaliste un petit peu et je pense que
concarneau joue tranquillement pour
l'instant bien sûr j'y crois encore ces
lois que je suis leur dos ou une micro
bien sûr je serai je rentrais chez moi
au retour des vestiaires pas de miracle
ou ne reviendra pas concarneau marque
même un troisième but par
l'intermédiaire dit daz à la 84e minute
pour mettre fin à l'épopée des yvelinois
ce qu'en finale 3 0
[Musique]
déçue déçue déçue de la philosophie du
match parce qu'en première mi temps je
pense qu'on les a trop respectés et
après en deuxième on a été plus haut on
a montré qu'on avait un peu de qualité
mais bon c'est le football comme ça
après cette parenthèse coupe de france
ou de voir plonger rapidement dans le
quotidien du championnat de r3 où il
occupe la dernière place
prochain match dimanche 14 janvier sur
le terrain de choisy le roi on continue
à parler de coupe de france mais cette
fois ci en basket dans le chaudron de
rémiller le chesnay versailles qui
évolue au niveau régional n'a pas réussi
à renverser les espoirs de châlons reims
en 32e de finale les yvelinois se sont
inclinés à la dernière seconde 83 à 81
dans une fin de match à suspense
retour sur cette rencontre avec nicolas
landry il reste neuf secondes dans ce
dernier quart temps versailles et
châlons reims sont dos à dos dernière
possession pour les espoirs rémois les
versailles et doivent défendre pour
créer l'exploit dernier rebond favorable
à chalon versailles s'incline 80 à 83
ça fait mal parce que j'aurais préféré
perdre de 10,15 points plutôt que que
comme ça sur un dernier tir
vous savez c'est toujours embêtant de
perdre les deux équipes sont vraiment
venu pour jouer cette équipe c'est une
bonne et jeune équipe elle est bien
entraîné il était vraiment préparé pour
gagner le chesnay versailles a débuté ce
match avec un avantage de 21 points face
au jeune espoir de châlons reims équipe
évoluant en pro a
des yvelinois ont tenté de maintenir cet
écart mais les approximations techniques
face à la vitesse des rémois permet aux
visiteurs de revenir à un point des
versailles et 47 à 46 on avait à coeur
de montrer vraiment une meilleure une
meilleure prestation que ce qu'on avait
fait en première mi temps
on avait perdu beaucoup de ballons et on
avait un petit peu tergiversé sur nos
choix
après voilà
en deuxième mi-temps on a eu un sursaut
d'orgueil ça nous a pas permis créer un
gros écart même si à un moment on est
encore à plus 8
soutenu par un public venu en nombre le
chesnay-versailles resta auteurs
présents au rebond au contre et avec
plus de réussite aux tirs et versailles
et reprenne mais huit points d'avancé à
trois minutes de la fin du quatrième
quart temps le score 81 73 et on était
prévenu on savait qu effectivement c'est
une belle équipe avec un secteur
intérieur dominant enfin celle des très
bons joueurs avec également de
l'expérience plus de maturité
cette maturité va permettre aux joueurs
du chesnay versailles de rebondir en
championnat de régionale 2 après cette
première défaite de la saison
un mot de course à pied à présent le
premier marathon des yvelines s'est
tenue ce dimanche matin à cerner la
ville plus de 300 participants ont pris
le départ de cette 5e édition dans la
commune malgré une météo capricieuse un
reportage de nicolas drori il ne fallait
pas être frileux pour cette cinquième
édition du marathon de cerner la ville
les coureurs ont fait leur échauffement
dans le gymnase durant la course une
moyenne de 5 degrés celsius un vent
assez fort
les conditions de ce marathon organisé
en hiver quand on organise une course en
été on espère avoir on pense avoir du
beau temps et on n'a pas toujours du
beau temps tandis que quand on organise
en hiver on s'attend pas à voir du beau
temps et on n'a pas du beau temps le
sportif cet enfant simplement de courir
mais il attend des challenges et le
challenge pour qu'on leur propose c'est
de couvrir tout de suite après les fêtes
après les bulles de
du jour de l'an et de venir directement
aux bonnes résolutions de sportive avec
un départ rapide à travers les villages
de bullion et la celle les bordes
gaspard fombonne vainqueur des trois
dernières éditions creuse l'écart avec
ses deux poursuivants david webster et
didier subileau ont terminé dix minutes
derrière gaspard ils cavalent tout seul
tout seul avec un temps de 2 40 donc
c'est vraiment énorme là c'est un autre
niveau après pour gagner dix minutes je
vous faut vraiment être très fort moi je
pense que je manquais un peu de volume
sinon on voyait peut-être moyens de
descendre sous les souhaits de 40 mais
dollars de là à nyon à inquiéter le
premier qu'on peut difficile aujourd'hui
objectif de gaspard fombonne pour cette
édition amélioré le record de l'an
dernier en descendant sous les 2 heures
39 minutes
c'est chose faite il a parcouru les 42
km en deux heures 38 minutes sur les
derniers kilomètres on avait le vent en
pleine face on était très exposée donc
la fin de course était vraiment
difficile au début ça allait je m'égare
d'une minute par rapport à l'an dernier
et d'une minute par rapport à 2015 donc
voilà dans trente ans je peux très
peut-être le record du coup avant le
record du monde de l'auvergnat déjà
donné rendez-vous à ses adversaires en
2019 pour tenter de battre cette
nouvelle performance
nous allons maintenant parler de
handball dans ce magazine le club de
monti le bretonneux a connu une première
partie de saison à mitigé chez les
filles le club est classé à la dernière
place du championnat de nationale 2
alors que l'équipe visé à la montée au
mois de septembre chez les garçons par
contre rien à signaler ils sont
actuellement deuxièmes en honneur
régional pour nous parler du club nous
recevons sur ce plateau le président
christophe reding bonsoir
alors tout d'abord on va parler des
filles qu'est ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
sur cette première partie de saison
alors on sait tous où viser le podium
voire la montée en dhr où les footeux
faits m'ont rien n'est fait encore
jusqu'à la fin de saison
on est parti sur un groupe reconstitué
pour partie et on a subi en fait
quelques blessures
c'est chez certaines deux joueuses
cadres qui a impacté malheureusement les
résultats
l'esprit de groupe les entraînements
donc par rapport à ça donc on était un
petit peu en difficulté dès à présent
nous avons une reprise des entraînements
qui est qui s'effectue en fait ce soir
avec un premier match ce week-end ou
contre aubervilliers où on escompte en
fait que ça ça revient comme l'année
dernière une remonte à da pourquoi pas
mais en tout cas on l'espère alors sur
le plan comptable on avait pour
l'instant aucune victoire à votre actif
est ce que ce n'est pas trop difficile à
gérer avec les choses c'est compliqué on
a quand même une victoire en coupe de
france sur le championnat effectivement
on a pas on a eu un premier match qui
était un match nul et puis après c'est
vrai qu'on a enchaîné quelques défaites
il faut qu'elle trouve le moral c'est
vrai qu'une victoire ça ça aide la
victoire savait toujours même pour faire
passer les petites douleurs
là il n'y a rien de tel que gagner des
matches vous en parlez vous avec les
choses bien sûr bien sûr mais on l'est
on essaie en fait le staff dirigeant en
est c'est comment dire de ne pas
dramatiser on essaye surtout de d'être
une d'être un support d'être une aide en
fait aux j'ose vous conservez votre
confiance en denys choulet l'entraîneur
de l'équipe
oui oui oui tout à fait rond s'est réuni
la semaine dernière
je lui en fait je lui je lui dois tout à
fait ma confiance je la renouvelle et je
souhaite en fait comme je vous l'avais
dit précédemment
lorsque je m'engage avec un entraîneur
ce n'est pas pour faire du court terme
ou du moyen terme c'est vraiment pour
avoir un projet de club
il emploie depuis un an environ il est à
l'arrêt depuis un an c'était un c'est un
ancien il est parti il est revenu et là
honnêtement on a un projet avec de la
formation des jeunes
l'intégration des plus jeunes en fait
c'est celle à l'idée est en fait on peut
pas se permettre enfin de changer tous
les six mois ou tous les ans
d'entraîneur donc sans éclat je continue
à passer oui tout à fait tout à fait il
arrive il a un message en fait il a un
projet de jeu qui lance un suivi sur les
filles et suivie sur les sur les plus
jeunes également l'année dernière vous
étiez dans le top 5 de nationale 2 cette
année vous êtes du coup à la dernière
place
est ce que le championnat et il peut
être finalement plus dur que la saison
précédente
non avec les équipes de haut niveau
n'ont pas pu durant le choc le plus dur
l'année dernière on a été on a vécu un
peu la même chose après la descente de n
1 et n 2 où on avait beaucoup de filles
qui ont king qui nous avait quittés on
est reparti sur en fait sur une
reconstruction est en soi
à la même époque on est également
dernier est en fait on a fini 5e sur en
fait une succession de victoires pour là
jusqu'à la fin jusqu'à la fin de saison
ça va devenir une habitude avant tignes
on va vous fait pas un produit
d'habitude c'est comme un petit peu
stressant mais il faut que la mayonnaise
prenne voilà clairement sur sa et
caisses qu'il faudra améliorer sur cette
deuxième partie de saison
ses manières la question sur les filles
en fait clairement de la confiance la
confiance en soi chez escher l est
et comment dirais-je certaines têtes un
peu plus d'acidité et kiki qui quitte à
manquer alors du côté des garçons par
contre tout va bien ils sont pour
l'instant 2e du championnat
c'était un objectif en début de saison
alors l'objectif la montée à ce que
finalement ils sont dans la course à la
montée
alors l'objectif en fait on souhaite que
cette équipe va y est c'est que c'est
expliqué ce équipes masculines en fait
montent en excellence région depuis
plusieurs années bon il nous manque
toujours un des finalités c'est un
groupe voilà s'est soumis aussi à des
blessures ces différentes choses et là
par le biais en fait d'une entente avec
le club de voisins qui eux l'année
dernière était en excellence donc on a
une certaine expérience de quelques
joueurs qui viennent s'intégrer à notre
notre collectif il vient en fait c'est
au fait avec en fait une certaine
expérience aussi d'un niveau
supérieur donc ça c'est quand même
plaisant et puis en fait on a aussi un
bel esprit de groupe qui est là depuis
plusieurs années une envie une envie
collective en fait de monter aujourd'hui
il faut qu'ils le veuillent pas s'ils le
veulent ils iront voilà c'est un peu
c'est ça c'est vraiment c'est se dire
voilà on va aller jusqu'au bout on veut
jouer cette montée par contre grosse
difficulté par rapport aux années
précédentes c'est qu'en fait avant on
était sur une ligue ile de france ouest
cette année en fait on est sur l'île on
a fait une fusion des ligues avec l'est
et donc on est sur une une ligue
beaucoup plus importante est en fait
avoir en contre des équipes assez assez
dur sur le côté est donc le challenge
est d'autant plus dure vous pensez qu'il
peut y avoir deux équipes en nationale
d'ici les prochaines saisons une chez
les filles que chez les garçons ça peut
être possible
alors on c'est pour ça qu'avec les clubs
du bassin de saint quentin on met en
place des différentes ententes
aujourd'hui plaisir à un groupe en fait
en nationale 3 l'idée c'est en fait ces
deux d'entre eux comme dire qu'on
s'entende conforme des jeunes pour
pouvoir alimenter sa dans un premier
temps une plus haut niveau régional en
fait serait en fait a souhaité en tout
cas pour pour montigny si on fait
plaisir vient à développer encore son
niveau ben oui effectivement nous c'est
on veut suivre le monsieur pour le
visage abl voilà c'est fait dans ce sens
là merci à vous d'être passé sur ce
plateau christophe reading on souhaite
avoir fait mine de
montigny-le-bretonneux d'engranger leur
première victoire de l'année contre
aubervilliers ce samedi à 20h30 au
gymnase pierre de coubertin et aux
garçons de montée en fin de saison
merci beaucoup merci michael et à
bientôt je vous propose à présent de
partir du côté de la piscine aqua mundo
de saint cyr l'école
armé de ses palmes et de sa combinaison
paul gérard tente de repousser chaque
semaine les limites du corps humain en
apnée dynamique à 18 ans l'apnéiste est
considéré comme l'un des meilleurs en
france
son portrait en montage de jus le grenat
ville paul gérard 18 ans est l'un des
meilleurs apnéistes français de sa
génération hauteur de 167 m aux derniers
championnats de france le jeune prodige
a réussi à se faire un nom dans le monde
de l'apnée dynamique une discipline qui
l'a découvert en 2012 en fait c'est ma
mère
mon grand-père il pratiquait depuis tout
petit
en fait ma mère l'âge de 12 ans elle m'a
dit pas pourquoi ça te dirait d'aller
plonger une fois ou deux et puis on est
parti pour jouer et puis ça m'a
directement plus et puis en fait nous
tenir
donc à partir de là à l'apnée
aujourd'hui paul est addict à ce sport à
la playlist s'entraînent une à trois
fois par semaine pendant deux heures
entre saint germain en laye saint cyr
l'école des sessions qui lui permet
également de travailler son mental sous
l'eau au début je pense à ma glisse donc
je pense à l'effet clos à sur mon corps
et puis petit à petit au fur et à mesure
je commence à me dire que c'est dur la
cnec que je souffre mais
mais j'essaie justement de passer à
autre chose et de nous concentrer sur ma
glisse des entraînements qui ont payé le
jeune sportif d'un mètre 86 vient d'être
sélectionné pour participer à un stage
avec les espoirs de l'équipe de france
en février prochain à mulhouse
je suis assez impatient d'y être chassé
impatient de rencontrer tout le monde de
partager
d'échangé pour presser 3,5 pouces une
expérience qui lui permettra peut-être
de réaliser l'un de ses plus grands
objectifs aller au delà des 200 m en
apnée d'ici les deux prochaines années
amateurs de sensations fortes paul
gérard ne manque pas d'ambition il
participera également à la et ron mann
de nice le 24 juin prochain
au programme de l'épreuve 3 8 km de
natation 180 km de vélo avec 2000 mètres
de dénivelé et pour finir un marathon à
18 ans un pôle sera l'un des plus jeunes
participants de l'épreuve
un autre talent yvelinois fait également
parler de lui en ce moment sur la toile
son nom à louis à boniface le very roi
de 20 ans totalise plusieurs millions de
vues en faisant de la scala klein un
sport qui ressemble au funambulisme créé
dans les années 80 aux etats unis le
concept les sportifs doivent réaliser
des figures sur une sangle élastique
tendu une discipline dans laquelle louis
boniface le prodige de la verrière
excellent il est l'un des meilleurs
européens à l'heure actuelle on nous
parlait de cette discipline et de son
parcours nous sommes avec lui boniface
en plateau bonsoir bonsoir
alors pourquoi vous êtes vous lancé dans
cette discipline donc actuellement je me
suis lancée tout simplement parce que à
la base je suis gymnastes et donc je
cherchais par la suite arrêté le sport
de haut niveau
en gymnastique et donc avoir un sport
continuant dans l'acrobatie général et
je suis tombé là dessus puisque mon père
est tout simplement grimpeur la
slackline vient de l' escalade et donc
du coup j'ai vu que je pouvais marcher
j'ai vu sur internet que je pouvais
faire arrêter petit salto des choses
comme ça et c'est venu
c est vers quel âge moi ya cinq ans donc
maintenant j'avais 15 ans 15 16 ans
voilà et comment avez vous connu
justement ce sport qui est qui est peu
médiatisé en france
finalement c'est passé par voltaire
exactement tout simplement en fait dans
l'est dans les magasins d escalade ils
vont des des slackline maintenant ça
c'est vraiment démocratiser un peu
partout mais
voilà comment j'ai découvert ça il m'a
offert ça et puis j'ai commencé à en
faire un tout petit peu et c'est surtout
sur internet que j'ai vu que je pouvais
développer ça et donc voilà
alors quelles qualités doit t'on at
avoir pour être un bon cela kleiner
alors pour être un bon cela kleiner ya
pas de deux choses particulières qu'il
faut avoir parce que c'est quand même un
sport d'équilibré
du coup on travaille énormément la
motricité
on travaille énormément l'iso mettrie du
corps etc
par contre pour la partie freestyle là
il faut vraiment avoir un corps solide
ils ont une bonne préparation physique
une bonne endurance et un bon repère
dans l'espace pour la faveur une bonne
acrobaties donc sur une base de gymnase
trampolinistes ou être sportes
il faut pas avoir le vertige c'est
exactement alors ça pour les personnes
qui souhaitent un moteur il faut pas
avoir le vertige
là c'est vraiment un combat sur soi même
et voilà l'appréhension du vide elle est
vraiment elle est vraiment présente
lorsque par exemple on est dans les
gorges du verdon ou encore plus près on
a le ce soir du côté d'auxerre qui sont
les falaises à proximité de la région
parisienne
alors je disais précédemment vous êtes
l'un des meilleurs en europe est ce que
vous attendiez à atteindre ce niveau
quand vous avez commencé ah oui
complètement complètement complètement
en fait sortait vraiment du haut niveau
en gymnastique j'étais au pôle espoir de
vélizy je m'entraînais 25 à 30 heures
par semaine
et lorsque j'ai découvert ce sport de
toute façon je me suis dit que je me
laisse un an pour faire champion de
france et donc j'ai commencé à
m'entraîner tous les jours dessus
et puis c'est vrai que venant d'inde
impasse et gymnique
je savais que j'avais un beau potentiel
dessus qui fait que actuellement
je suis dans le top 3 top 5 européen ce
qui est déjà vraiment pas mal du tout
combien d'heures vous partirez vous
faites de la slackline par semaine alors
pas tellement avant je faisais beaucoup
plus je faisais une quinzaine d'heures
là maintenant je suis plutôt à 10 heures
mais par contre je fais beaucoup de
travail à côté c'est à dire que
actuellement bas j'ai arrêté la
gymnastique pour faire que du trampoline
et et amélioré en fait mon acrobaties
mon repère dans l'espace tout ce qui est
travail d' équilibre un petit peu comme
on peut faire chez le kiné ou autre et
là par contre là par contre je passe pas
mal de temps là-dessus parce que sur la
slackline en elle-même au niveau du
rebond
il ya beaucoup de contraintes notamment
au niveau du dos du coup pour cela on
est beaucoup d'exercices en place alors
vous avez également réussi ce que
personne n'avait réussi auparavant à une
triple rotation comme on peut le voir en
ce moment à l'écran
comment fait-on pour réaliser ce type de
figure or comment c'était une première
mondiale
voilà donc c'était une première mondiale
comment on fait tout simplement on
s'entraîne beaucoup au trampoline un
réaliser un triple avant pour travailler
notamment les repères visuels et
l'oreille interne parce que laure et
internet ont beaucoup pour pour se
repérer et après il faut le grain de
folie et la persévérance
mon ami neuf sessions de trois heures
vous l'avez tenté combien de fois au
total
pas beaucoup à peu près 3 4 fois par
session
donc moins d'une trentaine de faux est
ce que vous avez peur encore quand vous
faites de la slackline oh oui oui oui on
a peur c'est le but
en tout cas si j'ai pas peur j'estime
que je me suis mal entraînés ou qu'il
faut que je voie mes revois mes
objectifs
actuellement je travaille sur une
nouvelle figure voilà je peux pas en
dire plus mais mais oui j'ai peur j'ai
le respect du mondial voilà exactement
ça fait maintenant ça fait plusieurs
mois que je suis dessus voilà sur de
deux mois et demi de travail
j'ai dû laisser y concrètement peut-être
une quinzaine de fois donc voilà il ya
beaucoup de préparation mentale
préparation physique parce que les chocs
c'est quand même ce qu'aime pas facile à
encaisser et vous faites également des
vidéos artistiques qui sont vu des
millions de fois sur internet
pourquoi avoir choisi de faire ce type
de vidéos et bien tout simplement parce
que la slackline aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas vraiment de deux grosses
compétitions officielles c'est pas il
n'y a pas de fédération
que ce soit en france ou à
l'international n'y a pas en tout cas de
fédération qui organise des compétitions
c'est un peu comme tous les sports
extrêmes ans et laisser les marques qui
organise cela
moi je me suis dis bah voilà pourquoi
pas aller dans un monde artistique
sortir un petit peu de l'ordinaire et
donc du coup on en est arrivé là
avec une grille ou qui réalise et vidéos
voilà qui réalise toutes mes vidéos avec
sa coopérative de samouraï
depuis peu tout simplement
après le côté artistique on a voulu
faire passer des messages
ce qui rend vraiment un intérêt à la
vidéo notamment édouard et je trouve ça
vraiment vraiment intéressant on a aimé
on était jeunes à ce moment là on avait
on avait 16 16 ans 16 ans et demi que
lorsqu'on a fait notre plus gros projet
vidéo actuellement retravailler encore
sur deux projets artistiques avec
d'autres formats vidéo plutôt
documentaire des choses comme ça
toujours pour transmettre des messages
et je trouve qu'il ya vraiment d'intérêt
au delà de la performance du snack liner
la question est ce que vous comptez vous
arrêter un jour très rapidement alors
ils 10 secondes
non franchement je ne compte pas
m'arrêter en tout cas tant que je peux
marcher je serai toujours sur l'eau
stagne
merci à vous et louis boniface si on
rappelle que ses lacets klein est très
difficile
enfin très dangereuse pour les enfants
et que tout le monde ne va pas essayer à
la maison merci les passer sur ce
plateau en tout cas louis boniface on
continuera évidemment à vous suivre sur
tv 78 temps passe maintenant notre page
agenda
[Musique]
on commence cet agenda par de la boxe le
grand combat franco-français entre
marvin petit samir kasmi est programmé
le 20 janvier prochain au palais des
sports marcel cerdan de levallois
si l'élan courtois de 26 ans vainqueur
de son combat il remportera la ceinture
wba intercontinentale et fera son entrée
dans le top 10 mondial pour préparer au
mieux ce rendez vous crucial pour la
suite de sa carrière l'élan courtois se
prépare depuis une quinzaine de jours en
enchaînant les mises de gants on écoute
au micro de tv 78 ce qui va faire la
différence c'est que son va dire c'est
celui qui est le plus près mais là je
pense que je suis plus prêt que lui il
est probable qu'on les prendra budget
mais moi je connais tout le monde est
prenable après dans la vie il faut
s'entraîner il faut pas penser à
l'adversaire il faut s'entraîner dur dur
dur et après voilà ce que vous remonte
sur le ring jour le jour même et on dit
que c'est la guerre quoi marvin petit
n'a connu qu'une seule défaite dans sa
carrière en 24 combats c'était en juin
2013 contre yvan mendy
à noter également dans vos agendas un
tournoi de badminton est programmée ce
week-end au palais des sports
d'elancourt plus de 350 joueurs venus de
toute la france vont s'affronter en
double le samedi des matches hommes et
femmes sont programmées le dimanche ce
sera au tour des double mixte l'entrée
est gratuite pour les spectateurs en
ball-trap reçoit ce samedi 13 janvier à
18 heures argenteuil en 32e de finale de
coupe de france départementale et
victoire les trappistes pourrez accéder
aux finales régionales si vous voulez
suivre la rencontre le match est
programmé au complexe sportif
youri gagarine au tour précédent trappe
l'avait emporté et 39 à 38 contre meudon
grâce un but à la dernière seconde
toujours à trappes mais cette fois ci en
football l'équipe senior recevra plus
tôt ce dimanche 14 janvier à 15 heures
pour le compte de la 13e journée de
régionale 4 victoire impérative pour les
trappistes qui sont actuellement
neuvièmes du championnat trois petits
points de la zone de relégation après
avoir été sur le podium en début de
saison trappe devra réaliser l'exploit
contre le 6e plus tôt pour remonter au
classement
enfin du cyclisme pour refermer ce
magazine la présentation officielle du
paris nice 2018 se tiendra ce mardi 9
janvier à l'hôtel du département à
versailles
c'est une certitude la mythique course
au soleil créé en 1933 partira une
nouvelle fois depuis les yvelines au
mois de mars pour la neuvième année
consécutive au moment de rejoindre le
sud de la france
bois d'arcy en 2017 les cyclistes
devront passer selon les toutes
premières rumeurs du côté de l'encours
pour cette 76e édition
réponse demain aux alentours de midi
c'est la fin de celui de sport merci
d'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]